welcome back to cbs morning's where the
war in ukraine remains our top story
thousands of ukrainians who fled their
country looking for protection from the
russian invasion have started arriving
in poland yesterday the polish
government temporarily lifted the
quarantine rules at the border with
ukraine christina rafini is near that
border in the village of medica poland
christina good morning
good morning ukrainians are walking to
poland with optimism and fuel and short
supply they're leaving their cars at
home and coming across the border behind
me on foot since we've been here this
morning we've seen a lot of families
many with small children dragging bags
even dogs we talked to one woman and her
teenage daughter who walked 18 hours
nonstop we asked why they didn't leave
sooner and she said they just never
thought it would get this bad now as we
drove south overnight from warsaw
overnight the gas line started getting
longer one station was cash only and the
manager said that's because so many
people have been trying to pull money
out of the atms the credit card systems
are going in and out now we also visited
an arena on the outside of jeshuf the
largest city in the area where a few
thousand members of the 82nd airborne
are camped out there are now nearly 5
000 u.s service members here in poland
and 14 000 deployed to nato allies from
the baltics to romania to make sure the
conflict and the russians stay on the
other side of that border gate now a
little closer to the entry point a
little way over my shoulder here we met
two young women from belarus who said
they're here offering rides and help to
the refugees as they come over they had
to leave their country about six months
ago and they said they know how hard it
is to come to a new place with nothing
and start over
christina raffini near the poland
ukraine border christina thank you very
much